welcome to this video round four of the
candidates tournament in County man disc
and this video is about the game
kayaking against Apollo so to par off
uncharacteristically the only player
without a decisive result is played
three draw so far playing black against
kayaking who had lost this game against
against whom against scrum nakritin not
to so he's on minus one and yeah minus
one after three rounds it's not too
great I mean at the end you will need
plus form probably or plus three at
least and if you r minus one you need to
somehow get four wins in without losing
a game so it's it's time to win to win
something um yeah T'Pau love is not in
dire need to win but the next couple of
rounds like two rounds then there should
be some kind of win otherwise you won't
catch up so let's see what happens
kayaking surprisingly opening was c4
that really surprised me I was really
expecting um 1.e4 for sharp sicilian or
i'm not sure yeah you never know what
would would had happened but my own
expectation was was a sicilian so
neither or four or something but instead
we get a seafoam yeah topalov place this
line 'if I've and here we have the
reversed Sicilian dragon yeah in fact
while the dragon the original dragon um
is often associated with wild text well
the white side is castling long in the
Sicilian and black Shawn and we've got
this race situations the reversed dragon
here
opening is a very very positional
opening very strategically focused and
this is because yeah what one simple
tactic effect actually look at this
position here with black to move if you
are ya want to play it sharply go for a
long castling you basically have to
start with visual b6 Bishop e6 f6
cuidese having this kind of setup and
the point is that if you go be sure me
six yeah this is simply not a brilliant
move because after yeah you can also
play this this immediately but it's
better to first castle the castles here
if black now tries to go for this long
castle set up he has to play f6
basically now and why do play deform and
this is the the big difference to the
dragon well Black has played an early d6
here in one move we can play d4 the
white side and here Black is almost yeah
blog is in big trouble already actually
you are never going to get an eagle
position here again it's just too much
happening in the center of the board and
it's too its tools too clumsy blacks
development yeah if he takes for example
after 94 it's already very problematic
something like that is its best play but
here why does just much much better it's
got this fantastic fantastic bishop on
the long diagonal and black has nothing
really to to counter that yeah this
deform idea by white is the reason why
the sharp setups are really not working
in fact the normal way for black to play
zone the night back to be six here one
important thing is that Bishop e7 is
also not working you 2nite xe5
this tactic yeah something like that is
just winning upon let's say can to take
here yeah you want just one line and
yeah maybe here it's just a pawn for for
absolutely nothing so like a normally
even retreat cm to prepare Bishop e7 you
can play Bishop e6 but then there's
always this DVD for idea as mentioned
before okay so this is the basic
position of the reversed dragon and
kayaking is playing d three castles and
now he plays Bishop to e3 yeah this is
in fact at least that was to me somewhat
of a surprise in recent years and recent
years or so yeah let's say in the last
25 years recent is not too too precise a
description it was I thought established
that a three years the way to go here to
fight for something initiating queenside
play with B form and normally it goes
like that a three let's say Bishop b6
and then before and it goes from there
white often both fianchetto with the
bishop and tries for ideas like that the
c5 squares of course a critical square
where often a night should it p.m. if
what strategy is successful yeah this so
long for a long time has been
established as the main line important
ideas that if black tries to prevent
before then switching back to Bishop e3
is an important point here sometimes you
can even capture on b6 and damage the
pawn structure yeah but well kayaking is
simply playing Bishop e3 immediately
which is the way this opening was
handled yeah let's say in the nineteen
sixty
or let's say maybe 70s but nowadays it's
believed to be relatively harmless so I
was curious to see what the new ideas
and after Bishop 6 Roxy one rookie 8
played a 3 yeah what exactly is is why
it's big idea okay you can try to
combine this a 3 before with Bishop e3
maybe that but look at what's the
polymers plane i played night back to d5
yeah it looks like a temple loss but we
we had seen before that for crude reason
the night had to retreat and here this
is basically um inviting this exchange
as the night only three is sort of
double attacking two pieces white
exchanges which makes lots of sense and
now Bishop takes d5 yeah and around here
I was really asking myself okay how is
the kayaking now trying to get something
here the normal ideas queen a for Bishop
c5 p.m. and this is what he tried but
look what happened rooks is free and now
Bishop to f6 yeah Roxy three ads not
clear that you must play that wide also
could have played Bishop c5 immediately
but black has Bishop f6 all the time and
this is an interesting way to play black
just avoids the trade and sort of
ignores this this Bishop here it has
various ideas one idea can be knight to
e7 and maybe Knight to g5 later after
this Bishop has moved or you can try to
reroute this Bishop to g7 yeah and of
course there's this idea to play Knight
d4 at the right moment this also common
motif yeah this Bishop on c5 is bit yeah
it's it's not doing much really so I'm
Chacon is first playing on the on the
sea farm yeah here if I was a threat so
he moves the rook again yeah 97 Roxy one
nc6 yet around here my suspicion was
that they are they won't be happening so
watching this game anymore to be honest
it feels like black has already are very
comfortably equalized look at the
structure it's got this healthy pawn
structure a good bishop on d5 and if
white moves the knight on f3 he will be
able to exchange the fianchetto bishop
after the exchange the night we'll have
a nice square another idea that black
can go for its night f5 to deform still
yeah white as has two ideas in this
position one is the minority attack like
before a4 b5 the other idea could be to
play d4 at the right moment like default
or the minority attack and we see some
of those ideas in the game Bishop g5
yeah this is exchanging two pairs of
minor pieces and does not look overly
ambitious but how actually are you going
to improve on that it's not like this
move is not yeah leading to to anything
to be honest but I'm not sure what what
else to recommend for white I think that
black is just quite comfortable let's
say before for argument's sake look at
this yeah and black is getting good play
in the center those two rooks they look
at a protected porn on c6 down and so
simply not not so great yeah Knight a5
and d 4 s.s real problem as he went for
Bishop g5 and like simply exchanged
those two pairs of minor pieces
and now he maneuvered the night to d6
which is a pretty decent square it
covers b7 it covers f7 and it controls
some important squares that white might
use as um yeah positions for s pieces
yeah but should why do I mean I think
with a Kraken did the best possible
thing patty three and now exchanged
nights and so we have a position with
only heavy pieces on the board it's
probably equal but they didn't didn't
agree to a draw you know some some
approving moves and yeah now white only
has one plan left in the position and
this is a4 b5 I'm in a minority attack
to at the end play against a weakish
pawn on c6 or b7 g6 bite Apollo and now
okay i can played a for you and here we
are to be honest only really interesting
spot in this game I'm not spoiling too
much I guess by telling you that a four
in fact is a slide slide in accuracy by
K Arkin he should have played dumb move
like that this is as mentioned allowing
something an interesting move by black
if you like you can use this position as
a an exercise for the black side and try
to find the the best move here for black
to worm yeah too yeah sort of try it try
a little bit try a little bit even to to
play for an advantage I'll be silent for
a couple of seconds so that you can
pause the video comfortably
alright so I'll show you the move the
ball of plate rook t4 very very funny
move just putting the rook on a
protected square but it's this
configuration that that allows it and
this move can really shocked a player if
you're hunting didn't see it before yeah
it's not objectively leading to so much
to be honest but it certainly is the end
for for any hopes that white might have
entertained before note that in this
position black played g6 if you would
have played that here it's actually a
massive blunder do two takes takes and
again you can use this as an exercise if
you like find the best move for white
ear yeah white has a very nice shot here
with rookie takes c6 that's quite funny
yeah rook takes c6 now all pieces are
hanging the Queen this rook this rook
but the older the hotel rule applies you
can only take one at a time and enter
some moves you can easy rule out cannot
take the Queen because check checkmate
in two cannot move this rook again chat
you to checkmate so yeah you need to
take this rook yeah now rocks 26 and
it's it's quite funny again black cannot
take the Queen or the rook due to the
mates and do I just wanna pawn and
blackest a completely busted wide will
play rook takes c6 next move and I just
win the game so this is why to pile of
played g6 to avoid the background
weakness and kayaking is right falling
right into this little trap I guess he
must have overlooked it really and maybe
I don't know but it's a it's because it
looks so so funny too he played a 4 and
this lets before hang so you cannot even
retreat the Queen yeah because yeah like
just take the ball and so he he talked
on deform takes here and here again I
was surprised but maybe a kayak ins
decision was that was right he played a
queen takes e6 to get to position where
he has two rooks again the Queen and a
pawn I thought you would just go for the
draw with Queen f3 this is a very simple
draw black takes and white is easily
going to draw the syrup endgame he has a
slightly in the words of it because of
to pawn islands against just one island
but it still should be a very easy draw
the king is quick to enter the game and
fulfill a useful role by protecting a
weakness and you select b-52 exchange of
everything so this was an easy draw and
it took only six and went for this
position maybe he thought that well ok
it's a position upon down but black has
absolutely no idea to make any progress
and maybe if the power off gets over
ambitious with which happens sometimes
he wants to really win the games and
which is a good trade but sometimes he
overdoes it and place just too sharply
maybe he wanted to provoke to palo into
doing something too optimistic but it
didn't happen rook a queen d 62 of
course cover the pot and now a five
freezing the Queen side yeah NTM we see
that this is this has some fortress type
of qualities yeah the rook is protecting
this it's protecting the looks are
protecting each other so it's hard for
black to to attack anything without
especially without giving up the d4 pawn
and they made a couple of more moves h5
h4 King g7 and King g1 yeah it's it's
not like white can do anything king of
eight rooks you want it's just a bit of
a back and forth
thing yeah it's really a it's really
nothing that that right can try here
check here we got a couple of channel of
checks and here draw a grid the thing is
maybe kayaking was hoping that sao paulo
would play something like let's say f5
that has some some inherent risk to it
it really is let's say here and then
what maybe can try to to invade here and
it's maybe too optimistic the thing is
black can mmm cannot really make any
progress without pawn moves even and you
cannot really move any of those pawns
the only thing to you have to to do
would be f5 but it's seriously weakening
your own position this is a kind of a
case of draw where both sides and cannot
really do much to to improve and
therefore they they they must draw the
game almost us know where there's no
room for improvement so when ya this
ended in a draw we are how to assess
both play as performance of wine chances
to pile of has played fraud ross which
is solid of course and still he needs to
win a game at some point to get in
contention for the qualifying spot but
it's not yet lost in any case with four
drawers remember that last year our
kramnik only had I think plus one after
seven games and then started to win game
after game so on the t f+ 1 even it was
around the fifty percent margin so you
can always get something going later in
the tournament but yeah with four draws
the problem is is also if you don't get
a winner early you have absolute
no leeway in in terms of yeah losing a
game and still be in contention if you
are let's say play for drawers and lose
one year out of it simply and kayaking
needs to win a game badly and then in
contrast is on minus one and to be
honest this game felt a little bit like
em and a little bit too timid to me of
course those says he for openings the
flank openings they have some point to
it even in situations where you want to
win the game simply because contrary to
lots of let's say double king porn
openings you don't have so many pieces
traded off and you sort of delay the
fights to the to the middle and end game
but this game is simply didn't have
enough bite to it to to get anything
serious so seemed a bit a little bit too
yeah bit too timid to me alright I hope
you enjoyed it anyway I'd like this
little technical idea sir with root
deform there really wasn't so much else
to show in this game alright thanks for
watching